people of the internet welcome into
another video and as I understand it you
want to learn how to counter the
Norwegian Ridgeback egg it can be quite
a pain it actually just got banned for
one week in my region they actually
added this new feature where players
above a certain rank can vote on two
cards that they want to ban each week
and this one was at the top of the list
but there is a very I wouldn't say easy
way but there is a very powerful way to
counter this and in this video I'm going
to show you two examples one example of
it going very well and then another
example of you know maybe you don't get
the right card at the exact right time
and you have to make some adjustments
I'm going to show you an example of both
of them the biggest key to countering
the egg is the atmospheric charm it's
only a rare card should not be too hard
for you to get should not be too hard
for you to even upgrade it quite a bit
as well and again I'm saying this
completely as a free to play player so
here's the effect of this card this is
the big part right here that we want to
pay attention to applies a heel
reduction effect to units hit now the
funny thing about this guys is so many
of these players you can tell they have
just been relying lying solely on this
Norwegian Ridgeback just tearing through
the opponent and you can see him start
to panic and when they start to Panic
it's just GG it's game over once you
stop there one method of beating you
it's over this is just such an
incredible counter to this spell for a
number of reasons first of all the fact
that it lasts almost 10 seconds of
course you have the heel reduction as
well and it's not like another summon
they can't do anything about it the egg
is sitting there stationary all they can
do is panic and heal and most of the
time that's exactly what they try to do
but then it gives you plenty of time to
get something else ready to go to finish
off the egg all right so this first
example here is one where it goes very
very well and I'm pretty sure this was a
platinum match I did end up getting to
Diamond but I think this was a platinum
right here so you're going to run into a
lot of these when it's not banned anyway
you're gonna run into a lot of Norwegian
Ridgeback players in route to gold and
platinum and then probably still even in
Diamond as well
so right now you can just see okay so
there's the Norwegian Ridgeback and I
just got atmospheric charm immediately
put it on there and watch watch the
Panic watch the panic
she doesn't know what to do she's trying
to heal it she's trying to heal it and
then I'm just gonna fire an incendio on
there because that heel reduction effect
and see it's still didn't completely
finish it off but thankfully Ivy right
there was able to do the job for me if
not I would have had to cast something
else
and now watch how this match plays out
I get my Death Eater so she's able to
counter the Death Eater we're relatively
even right now but I've got the bombs
I've got the Pixies and it's just over I
mean the fight is already over
I don't know if I lose any other points
because this person just I mean it was
so clear they were completely reliant on
that one method and they're gonna try it
again here in a second so right now they
got Cassandra out so Cassandra helps
them a little bit I try to get incendio
to finish her off but Cassandra's so
good man did not take Cassandra out and
so there it is there's the Norwegian
Ridgeback again I've been holding
atmospheric charm I've got it ready put
it on there immediately I go ahead and
get the bombs ready because I look in my
hand I don't have an incendio ready yet
I don't have anything else ready so I I
fire the Pixies because I'm hoping
they'll be able to get over there in
time
she's still trying to heal it okay
atmospheric charm is worn off and then I
just out of desperation
I say I cannot let that Dragon get up
let's go let's throw Ron right here then
we get the monster book going on it now
look she he's still trying to heal it
even now trying to heal it
and so I just saw that moment as an
opportunity to basically end the fight I
mean there's still a chance there's
always a chance to come back in this
game it's kind of crazy how how easy it
is to come back
so now we're up we're up pretty big 2201
to 853 so I'm just sending a stack of
Monster books
they're just just absolutely destroyed I
mean so you can see like when the
players really depend on that one card
it's like you just have that one thing
to stop and the thing I've noticed as
I've been moving up through the rain and
then it's just over it's just GG it's
over but yeah what I've been noticing is
I've moved through the ranks is that the
best players are players that can adjust
they can adjust to different counters
they don't have just one move and
if they only are able to do one move
then they're not going to make it very
far especially once you start getting
into Platinum now this is an example of
it not going very well because sometimes
just luck of the draw you're not going
to have atmospheric charm in your hand
at the right time and they threw it
right away so they immediately throw
Norwegian Ridge back I throw my stack of
Monster books because I know
that they're gonna eat at it but then
they played Ron which was the perfect
counter like even though I have Ivy and
I get rid of Ron the damage is done I
throw another monster book just out of
desperation I still don't have
atmospheric charm notes it's finally
getting ready to come up next but it's
already too late the Norwegian Ridgeback
has hatched I'm ahead right now in
points but with that Norwegian Ridgeback
out in the field and me basically
completely out of MP I just have to
fight to survive right here I just have
to survive this that is that is all I'm
telling myself right now so I've got the
Pixies keeping the player occupied now
I'm this is panic mode this is panic
mode we have a Norwegian Ridgeback on
the field and then another one hatching
finally just in time I get the
atmospheric charm ready
and so even though I have this Norwegian
Ridgeback right in front of me I'm
worried about the egg more I get the
monster book on it because I know the
monster book's gonna keep eating at the
egg
then I get my Death Eater to help out a
little bit and then I just send Ron in I
send Ron in
so Ron goes over and now that egg is
done so I'm still look at look at how
that battle changed though it was 2100
to 1600 I was I was down right there
that's how much power the Norwegian
Ridgeback has and I guarantee you if
that other egg would have hatched it was
over so now right here they do another
egg and I've got this time I've got
atmospheric charm ready
and this is when the fight starts to
turn right here I've got the cats going
with the bombs
now look you can see them rushing over
because they know
they know that that that dragon is all
they had and the monster book the
monster book is also a great card to use
on it because until they take out the
monster book it'll just it'll just keep
chewing on it and so there we go we took
out another one right there now we've
got two Death Eaters I love getting the
Death Eater just outside of Cassandra's
Circle takes her out I send in the stack
of Monster books now we're roughly even
but I mean you guys can already see the
fight has turned
it is we have them cornered now we've
got the Death Eater we've got the
Monster books and then out of
desperation I love the out of
desperation play right there and see I
actually don't have oh yeah I did have
atmosphere charm okay I already played
it I was about to say and then I got the
Malfoy gang and it's just it's just GG I
actually can't believe how long some
people can survive sometimes like they
survive quite a while in that corner
back there now guys if you're curious
about upgrading cards which is going to
help you even more in the PVP mode then
check out the next video on the right
side of your screen that's going to be
very important to help you understand
all the currencies in Magic Awakening
should you pay real money what do you
have to pay real money for I'll explain
it in that video there as always thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon